Katrina: 但是
Katrina: But...
Katrina: 我觉得他今天穿这一身就很好看呀
Katrina: I think he looks great today.
Katrina: 本来就挺帅的呀
Katrina: He already looks quite handsome.
Katrina: 他这个年纪
Katrina: At his age...
Katrina: 你看看别人
Katrina: Look at others.
Katrina: 看看我爸
Katrina: Look at my dad.
Katrina: 本来就挺帅的呀
Katrina: He already looks quite handsome.
Katrina: 哈哈好女人当自强这句话说的好
Katrina: Haha, the saying "A strong woman makes her own way" is so true.
Katrina: 你放屁我爸这还长得不帅吗
Katrina: You're talking nonsense, my dad isn't handsome?
Katrina: 一天到晚趁我找不帅的
Katrina: All day long, you keep saying he isn't handsome.
Katrina: 自己找了个帅的
Katrina: But you found someone handsome yourself.
Katrina: 令人作呕
Katrina: Makes me sick.
Katrina: 你这开盲盒开成功了
Katrina: You really hit the jackpot with this blind box.
Katrina: 哦要要我
Katrina: Oh, I need...
Katrina: 我看电脑的
Katrina: I need to check the computer.
Katrina: 黑军技术部落
Katrina: Black Army Tech Blog.
Katrina: 哎呀谈谈什么恋爱
Katrina: Oh, talking about love?
Katrina: 还不如天天这样睡睡觉爽
Katrina: I'd rather just sleep like this every day, it's more satisfying.
Katrina: 主要是我当时知道
Katrina: The main thing is, when I found out...
Katrina: 他们全都有女朋友了
Katrina: They all had girlfriends.
Katrina: 以后特别轻松
Katrina: It was really easy going.
Katrina: 就全当哥们处
Katrina: We just treated each other as buddies.
Katrina: 然后就玩的特别开心
Katrina: And we had a lot of fun together.
Katrina: 哎你别说
Katrina: Hey, you know what?
Katrina: 我们这栋楼有工作人员
Katrina: In our building, all the staff...
Katrina: 还有那个男生全都有女朋友
Katrina: And all the guys have girlfriends.
Katrina: 包括那个清华本科生
Katrina: Even that Tsinghua undergrad.
Katrina: 我就说他为啥老要问我那个jellycat
Katrina: I was wondering why he kept asking me for the jellycat...
Katrina: 那个小狐狸的链接
Katrina: The link to that little fox.
Katrina: 我说你要送女生啊
Katrina: I asked if he was giving it to a girl.
Katrina: 他说对然后刚加了微信一看哦
Katrina: He said yes, and then I added him on WeChat and saw, oh...
Katrina: 有女朋友
Katrina: He has a girlfriend.
Katrina: 哈哈哈原来都有女朋友
Katrina: Hahaha, turns out everyone has a girlfriend.
Katrina: 跳呗
Katrina: Just jump then.
Katrina: 我觉得单身也挺爽
Katrina: I think being single is pretty awesome.
Katrina: 爽的一逼哎
Katrina: It's freaking awesome.
Katrina: 你是不懂单身的快乐
Katrina: You don't understand the joy of being single.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha.
Katrina: 这怎么这么搞笑
Katrina: Why is this so funny?
Katrina: 你懂不懂单身的快乐
Katrina: Do you understand the joy of being single?
Katrina: 一个人纯屌丝的生活真的爽飞
Katrina: Living a pure single life is really awesome.
Katrina: 每天想睡觉就睡觉
Katrina: Sleep whenever you want every day.
Katrina: 这个得等别的男生先喜欢我再说哎
Katrina: This has to wait until other guys like me first.
Katrina: 关我什么事呢
Katrina: What's it got to do with me?
Katrina: 等人家先追我再说
Katrina: Wait for them to chase me first.
Katrina: 唉搞不懂了
Katrina: Sigh, I don't get it.
Katrina: 当个屌丝好爽
Katrina: Being a single is so cool.
Katrina: 啊只想搞搞学习搞搞事业
Katrina: Ah, I just want to focus on studying and my career.
Katrina: 对啊搞着搞着
Katrina: Yeah, just keep at it.
Katrina: 然后你变好变优秀了
Katrina: And then you get better and excel.
Katrina: 人家就自然会喜欢你
Katrina: People will naturally like you.
Katrina: 嗯现在的人可是权衡利弊
Katrina: Hmm, people weigh the pros and cons nowadays.
Katrina: 权衡优秀的话
Katrina: If you excel,
Katrina: 那就能匹配到更好的人呀
Katrina: Then you can match with better people.
Katrina: 我呸
Katrina: Pfft.
Katrina: 我现在我现在无所谓
Katrina: Right now, I don't care.
Katrina: 我现在全国各地都行
Katrina: I can go anywhere in the country.
Katrina: 你管得着吗
Katrina: Is it any of your business?
Katrina: 你要是再这么挑下去
Katrina: If you keep being so picky,
Katrina: 我一个都不找
Katrina: I won't find anyone.
Katrina: 我一个都找不到好吗
Katrina: I won't find anyone, okay?
Katrina: 嗯你这个这个
Katrina: Hmm, you, this, this...
Katrina: 你就别管我了
Katrina: Just don't mind me.
Katrina: 我找个中国人就行了
Katrina: I'll just find a Chinese guy.
Katrina: 我不知道我以后去哪个城市
Katrina: I don't know which city I'll go to in the future.
Katrina: 我都不知道
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina: 哪个城市赚的钱多就去哪里
Katrina: I'll go wherever makes more money.
Katrina: 我不是那种
Katrina: I'm not the type.
Katrina: 无锡又没什么好公司
Katrina: There's no good company in Wuxi.
Katrina: 嗯那他九几年
Katrina: Hmm, in the 90s
Katrina: 那个时候是赶上了计算机的好时代啊
Katrina: It was the golden age of computers, you know?
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 我们这晚几年有点走下坡路了
Katrina: We've been going downhill a bit these past few years.
Katrina: 还是前几年的计算机发展都很好啊
Katrina: But the computer industry was doing great a few years ago.
Katrina: 这两年有点那个
Katrina: These past two years have been a bit...
Katrina: 是啊九几年
Katrina: Yeah, in the 90s...
Katrina: 那都有几年的工作经验了
Katrina: People already had years of work experience.
Katrina: 肯定价格涨
Katrina: Of course, prices went up.
Katrina: 华为那种公司就是你干的多给的多呀
Katrina: Companies like Huawei, the more you do, the more they pay.
Katrina: 加班
Katrina: Overtime.
Katrina: 本来就是啊
Katrina: That's just how it is.
Katrina: 这个东西你你学业跟事业
Katrina: You have to balance your studies and career.
Katrina: 你肯定要好好搞啊
Katrina: You definitely need to work hard.
Katrina: 至于那个爱情什么的
Katrina: As for love and stuff...
Katrina: 那也得看缘分
Katrina: That depends on fate.
Katrina: 所以说本来这个中国这么多人
Katrina: So, with so many people in China...
Katrina: 你碰到喜欢的就不容易
Katrina: It's not easy to find someone you like.
Katrina: 你还非得限定在你们附近
Katrina: And you want to limit it to your area?
Katrina: 咋可能嘛
Katrina: How's that even possible?
Katrina: 附近整个江阴市都认识这么多人
Katrina: In the whole Jiangyin city, I know so many people.
Katrina: 就是没有喜欢的
Katrina: But there's no one I like.
Katrina: 怎么办呢
Katrina: What can I do?
Katrina: 那我就一辈子单身
Katrina: Then I'll just be single forever.
Katrina: 一辈子单身也行
Katrina: Being single forever works too.
Katrina: 就是你们能不能接受
Katrina: But can you guys accept that?
Katrina: 反正我觉得
Katrina: Anyway, I think...
Katrina: 我肯定要找一个自己喜欢的
Katrina: I definitely want to find someone I like.
Katrina: 然后然后只要是中国的都行
Katrina: And as long as they're Chinese, it's fine.
Katrina: 还限定那么死
Katrina: Why limit it so much?
Katrina: 你知道现在找个正常男的有多难吗
Katrina: Do you know how hard it is to find a normal guy these days?
Katrina: 就是你往上面走很多那个男
Katrina: The higher you go, the more scheming they get.
Katrina: 他的那个心机也会更深
Katrina: They calculate the pros and cons even more.
Katrina: 他们也会更权衡利弊
Katrina: So...
Katrina: 所以
Katrina: Maybe...
Katrina: 哎说不定
Katrina: I mean, who knows?
Katrina: 所以我觉得这种小概率的事情
Katrina: So I think for these rare cases...
Katrina: 你就别给我再强加条件了好吗
Katrina: Stop adding more conditions, alright?
Katrina: 我们现在的眼光也没你们那么低
Katrina: Our standards aren't as low as yours.
Katrina: 不是说随便凑一个人就能过一辈子的
Katrina: We can't just settle with anyone for a lifetime.
Katrina: 我倒宁愿找不到喜欢的
Katrina: I'd rather not find someone I like.
Katrina: 我就不不谈恋爱
Katrina: I just won't date at all.
Katrina: 那我真不一定
Katrina: So, maybe I really won't.
Katrina: 我真但是我应该不会去北京
Katrina: Honestly, I don't think I'll go to Beijing.
Katrina: 生活压力太大
Katrina: The pressure of living there is too high.
Katrina: 我应该会去二线城市
Katrina: I'll probably go to a second-tier city.
Katrina: 要么就杭州
Katrina: Maybe Hangzhou.
Katrina: 南京没有杭州好
Katrina: Nanjing isn't as good as Hangzhou.
Katrina: 我要去肯定去杭州
Katrina: If I go, it’ll definitely be Hangzhou.
Katrina: 南京没有什么互联网公司
Katrina: Nanjing doesn't have many internet companies.
Katrina: 就想是杭州吧
Katrina: So, I'm thinking Hangzhou.
Katrina: 没有想到别的好一点的地方
Katrina: Can't think of any other better places.
Katrina: 北方哪有啊
Katrina: There's nowhere in the north.
Katrina: 如果你要走互联网城市的话
Katrina: If you're looking for an internet city.
Katrina: 北方就北京啊
Katrina: In the north, it's just Beijing.
Katrina: 哪啊还有什么地方
Katrina: What other places are there?
Katrina: 嗯不想去北上这种压力太大的城市
Katrina: I don't want to go to cities with such high pressure like Beijing or Shanghai.
Katrina: 一般像我们学校毕业的计算机的
Katrina: Generally, computer science graduates from our school.
Katrina: 去的最多的就是杭州跟深圳
Katrina: Mostly go to Hangzhou and Shenzhen.
Katrina: 这两个地方
Katrina: Those two places.
Katrina: 嗯工作机会多
Katrina: Lots of job opportunities there.
Katrina: 然后工资也开的很高
Katrina: And high salaries.
Katrina: 深圳很远
Katrina: Shenzhen is very far.
Katrina: 你能接受吗
Katrina: Can you handle that?
Katrina: 对啊那你刚刚又在
Katrina: Yeah, you just said that.
Katrina: 我又在限定什么呢
Katrina: What was I limiting?
Katrina: 我本来就说了第一个
Katrina: I originally said the first thing.
Katrina: 我找男朋友我可能就是无所谓
Katrina: When looking for a boyfriend, I don't really care.
Katrina: 只要自己喜欢就好
Katrina: As long as I like him.
Katrina: 然后第二个就是我的工作单位
Katrina: And the second thing is my job.
Katrina: 我根本就定不下来
Katrina: I can't settle on one.
Katrina: 我现在这个这一年到处走走
Katrina: This year, I'll just travel around.
Katrina: 就是看一下哪个城市
Katrina: Check out different cities.
Katrina: 去考察一下每个城市的人文
Katrina: Study the culture of each city.
Katrina: 还有他的城市发展
Katrina: And their urban development.
Katrina: 然后他的互联网发展什么什么的
Katrina: And their internet development and stuff.
Katrina: 多呆呆
Katrina: Stay longer.
Katrina: 多呆呆哎
Katrina: Stay longer, yeah.
Katrina: 我跟你说
Katrina: Let me tell you.
Katrina: 我昨天刷到了一个
Katrina: Yesterday, I came across.
Katrina: 珠海长隆的那个海洋馆
Katrina: The oceanarium at Zhuhai Chimelong.
Katrina: 他那里面是有真的那种鲸鱼
Katrina: They have real whales there.
Katrina: 很大很大的那种
Katrina: Really huge ones.
Katrina: 可以带刘宇辰去看看
Katrina: We could take Liu Yuchen to have a look.
Katrina: 是那种
Katrina: It's that kind.
Katrina: 好像中国只有那一家海洋馆有
Katrina: I think only one aquarium in China has it.
Katrina: 那个真的
Katrina: It's really
Katrina: 那种鲸鱼
Katrina: That kind of whale.
Katrina: 就是几十米长的那种
Katrina: Like, the ones that are tens of meters long.
Katrina: 只有珠海长隆海洋馆有
Katrina: Only the Zhuhai Chimelong Ocean Kingdom has them.
Katrina: 今年都行啊
Katrina: This year works.
Katrina: 今年年底就广州福州广州
Katrina: By the end of this year, Guangzhou and Fuzhou will be fine.
Katrina: 是真的
Katrina: It's true.
Katrina: 就不是跟我们看的那种海洋馆的鲨鱼
Katrina: It's not like the sharks we usually see in aquariums.
Katrina: 跟白鲸那种大小
Katrina: It's the size of a beluga whale.
Katrina: 是真的很大很大几十米那种
Katrina: It's really, really big, like tens of meters.
Katrina: 反正中国只有一家那种海洋馆
Katrina: Anyway, there's only one aquarium like that in China.
Katrina: 都行啊那今年年底都可以啊
Katrina: Anytime is fine, by the end of this year is okay too.
Katrina: 这有啥不可以的
Katrina: There's no reason why not.
Katrina: 不用花多少钱
Katrina: It doesn't cost much.
Katrina: 我感觉我经常出去玩都没花多少钱
Katrina: I feel like I often go out and don't spend much.
Katrina: 我去成都就花了2,000块钱
Katrina: I only spent 2,000 yuan when I went to Chengdu.
Katrina: 不是你们是这样子
Katrina: Aren't you guys the same?
Katrina: 你们给预算了以后
Katrina: After you give the budget...
Katrina: 我再去帮你们做攻略
Katrina: I'll help you make the plan.
Katrina: 就像你抱团一样
Katrina: Just like joining a tour group,
Katrina: 你给那个向导
Katrina: You give the guide
Katrina: 你说我们几个人的预算是多少
Katrina: your budget for the group,
Katrina: 他就帮你安排路线
Katrina: and they arrange the route for you.
Katrina: 就是怎么都能出去玩
Katrina: So you can always go out and have fun,
Katrina: 只是说你要玩的多一点还是少一点
Katrina: It just depends on how much you want to do.
Katrina: 这种
Katrina: That kind of thing.
Katrina: 就是去广州那一边呗
Katrina: Like going to Guangzhou,
Katrina: 就过年的时候去还比较暖和
Katrina: It's still quite warm during the New Year.
Katrina: 嗯西双版纳虫子比较多呦
Katrina: Yeah, there are a lot of bugs in Xishuangbanna.
Katrina: 我跟你说
Katrina: I'm telling you,
Katrina: 我从成都回来
Katrina: After I came back from Chengdu,
Katrina: 我就拢有两个地方一直痒
Katrina: I had two spots that were really itchy.
Katrina: 就是当时没有意识到被那个虫子咬了
Katrina: I didn't realize I was bitten by bugs at the time,
Katrina: 但是后来就一直痒一直痒
Katrina: but later they just kept itching.
Katrina: 没有就那紧那紧
Katrina: It wasn’t that bad, no need to go to the hospital.
Katrina: 还好啊没必要去医院
Katrina: It was fine, really.
Katrina: 哦我还好
Katrina: Oh, I’m okay.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 啊   昨天帮我去代课
Katrina: Oh, Ren Xiaohan helped me cover a class yesterday.
Katrina: 老师家长还没给钱
Katrina: The teacher and parents haven't paid yet.
Katrina: 我都忘记了
Katrina: I totally forgot.
Katrina: 就不是那个
Katrina: It’s not that...
Katrina: 本来带那个高二的那个女生嘛
Katrina: Originally, I was supposed to tutor that high school girl.
Katrina: 我被汉尼妈妈隔壁就邻居也想补
Katrina: But Hanni's mom's neighbor also wants tutoring.
Katrina: 就是我
Katrina: So I...
Katrina: 我回去以后就是周日上午一间
Katrina: When I get back, I’ll have one session on Sunday morning...
Katrina: 下午一家
Katrina: And another in the afternoon.
Katrina: 就同一个小区
Katrina: All in the same neighborhood.
Katrina: 然后对啊
Katrina: Yeah, that’s right.
Katrina: 就是那个男生上次来试了一堂课嘛
Katrina: The boy came for a trial lesson last time.
Katrina: 然后我就让   去帮我带了一堂
Katrina: So I asked Ren Xiaohan to cover it for me.
Katrina: 那个男生的课
Katrina: The boy’s lesson.
Katrina: 那男生家长给钱
Katrina: His parents paid.
Katrina: 就没有这个女生家长就给的快
Katrina: But the girl's parents pay faster.
Katrina: 我一般就会问一下
Katrina: I usually ask...
Katrina: 我说阿姨您给工资了吗
Katrina: I say, "Auntie, did you pay the salary?"
Katrina: 哦对哦
Katrina: Oh, right.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Katrina: 今天星一是吗
Katrina: Is it Xingyi today?
Katrina: 他妈妈他妈妈老那个
Katrina: His mom, his mom is always...
Katrina: 我都不知道怎么开口
Katrina: I don't even know how to start.
Katrina: 我上次就直接说了
Katrina: Last time, I just said it directly.
Katrina: 我说姐姐请问今天薪资结了吗
Katrina: I said, "Sis, has today's salary been settled?"
Katrina: 他马上转给我了
Katrina: She transferred it to me right away.
Katrina: 嗯嗯啊又想睡觉了
Katrina: Hmm, hmm, ah, I feel like sleeping again.
Katrina: 不知道啊
Katrina: I don't know.
Katrina: 6月中吧
Katrina: Mid-June, I guess.
Katrina: 最多6月中
Katrina: At most, mid-June.
Katrina: 然后我们宿舍应该还会搞一个
Katrina: Then our dorm should have another...
Katrina: 毕业旅行就
Katrina: ...graduation trip.
Katrina: 是4月底
Katrina: Like, end of April.
Katrina: 感觉
Katrina: Feels like...
Katrina: 感觉他们一点规划都没有
Katrina: Feels like they have no plan at all.
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Ugh.
Katrina: 弄不好的话那就人凑不齐也出去玩
Katrina: If we don't get it together, we might not even gather enough people to go.
Katrina: 随便如果他们非要玩静的
Katrina: Whatever, if they really want to go to Jingdezhen...
Katrina: 那就景德镇这种玩玩算了
Katrina: ...then let's just go to Jingdezhen and call it a day.
Katrina:     前两天生日
Katrina: Zou Xinyu's birthday was a couple of days ago.
Katrina: 他    把他给刷了
Katrina: He didn't pass the Polytech interview and got rejected.
Katrina: 就是他的分也不低啊
Katrina: His scores weren't low either.
Katrina: 怎么怎么的
Katrina: Whatever, whatever.
Katrina: 然后就调剂到上海海事大学
Katrina: Then he transferred to Shanghai Maritime University.
Katrina: 也是个211吧好像
Katrina: It's also a 211 university, I think.
Katrina: 嗯前两天不是老周生日吗
Katrina: Wasn't it Lao Zhou's birthday a couple of days ago?
Katrina: 就给老周定了个小蛋糕
Katrina: So we got Lao Zhou a small cake.
Katrina: 就感觉几几百年都不记得他生日
Katrina: It feels like we never remember his birthday for years.
Katrina: 我那天因为我们每天戴着眼镜
Katrina: That day, because we wear glasses every day,
Katrina: 不是要输日期吗
Katrina: we have to enter the date, right?
Katrina: 我就说418这个日子好熟悉
Katrina: I thought, "April 18th, this date feels so familiar."
Katrina: 是谁的生日吗
Katrina: Whose birthday is it?
Katrina: 我想是    的生日
Katrina: I thought it was Dong Xin's birthday.
Katrina: 还是   的生日呢
Katrina: Or maybe Zhou Xingyu's birthday?
Katrina: 我想    的生日好像是5月份
Katrina: I thought Dong Xin's birthday might be in May.
Katrina: 但是   的生日
Katrina: But Zhou Xingyu's birthday,
Katrina: 然后我跟   说没给你买礼物啊
Katrina: I told Zhou Xingyu, "I didn't get you a gift."
Katrina: 我说生日快乐
Katrina: I said, "Happy Birthday."
Katrina: 然后他跟我说我靠
Katrina: And he said to me, "Wow,"
Katrina: 你居然想起来了
Katrina: "You actually remembered."
Katrina: 想哭我说你别整的这么
Katrina: He wanted to cry. I said, "Don't make it so dramatic."
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina: 整的我好像从来不记得你的生日一样
Katrina: You're acting like I never remember your birthday.
Katrina: 这才叫纯哥们好吗
Katrina: That's what real bros are like, okay?
Katrina: 你看我跟老周这就纯普通异性关系
Katrina: Look at me and Lao Zhou, we just have a pure platonic relationship.
Katrina: 你看我之前的前男友
Katrina: Look at my ex-boyfriend,
Katrina: 那算什么异性关系
Katrina: What kind of relationship was that?
Katrina: 我们俩这就是几个月不说一句话
Katrina: We wouldn't talk for months, and only talk if there's something important.
Katrina: 然后有事说事的那种纯哥们
Katrina: That's the kind of pure bros we are.
Katrina: 老周是我的纯哥们
Katrina: Lao Zhou is my real bro.
Katrina: 真纯哥们
Katrina: Truly a bro.
Katrina: 太爽我再喜欢跟男神当纯哥们
Katrina: It's awesome. I love being pure bros with my crush.
Katrina: 所有人都被我玩成了哥们
Katrina: I turn everyone into bros.
Katrina: 这样看好大呀
Katrina: It looks so big from here.
Katrina: 这哪个房
Katrina: Which room is this?
Katrina: 这哪个房间哦
Katrina: 这是客厅是吧
Katrina: This is the living room, right?
Katrina: 主卧这么大
Katrina: The master bedroom is so big.
Katrina: 可以的
Katrina: It's nice.
Katrina: 羡慕啥呀
Katrina: What's there to envy?
Katrina: 我以后自己
Katrina: In the future, I...
Katrina: 买一套不就行
Katrina: ...can just buy one myself.
Katrina: 为啥找你打扫卫生还不如找阿姨呢
Katrina: Why ask you to clean when I can hire a maid?
Katrina: 你养好你的身体吧到时候
Katrina: Just focus on getting better, okay?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Katrina: （歌词）没有你在我有多难熬
Katrina: (Lyrics) It's so hard without you here.
Katrina: 是吗你这个以后是多少
Katrina: Really? What about later?
Katrina: 以后是要等我自己买了房子以后吗
Katrina: Do you mean after I buy my own house?
Katrina: 你说买猫啊就
Katrina: Are you talking about buying a cat?
Katrina: 你的意思是我自己花钱买猫
Katrina: You mean I should buy my own cat?
Katrina: 可以啊我现在就有钱买猫啊
Katrina: Sure, I can buy a cat right now.
Katrina: 每个月200块钱差不多
Katrina: About 200 bucks a month, right?
Katrina: 哎我自己工作自己租房子
Katrina: Hey, I work and rent my own place.
Katrina: 自己买一个
Katrina: I can buy one myself.
Katrina: 就肯定是买小猫
Katrina: Definitely getting a kitten.
Katrina: 那样养的才有感情啊
Katrina: That's how you build a bond.
Katrina: 对都是买那种一两个月的猫的
Katrina: Yeah, everyone gets cats that are a month or two old.
Katrina: 主要是小孩子成长
Katrina: It's mainly for the kids.
Katrina: 他有一个宠物
Katrina: Having a pet...
Katrina: 会对他包括他整个人格跟性格的培养
Katrina: ...helps develop their personality and character.
Katrina: 就会有很大的帮助
Katrina: It helps a lot.
Katrina: 就至少不会发展成以后那种虐猫的
Katrina: At least they won't grow up to be cat abusers.
Katrina: 心理变态
Katrina: Psychopaths.
Katrina: 对吧而且也会有一定的责任感
Katrina: Plus, they'll learn responsibility.
Katrina: 知道怎么跟小朋小动物相处啊什么的
Katrina: They'll know how to interact with animals and friends.
Katrina: 对小孩子的影还是还是有很大帮助
Katrina: It's really beneficial for kids.
Katrina: 只是说你知道家里有小孩
Katrina: Just, you know, when you have kids...
Katrina: 养养猫不是说对小孩不好
Katrina: ...raising a cat isn't bad for the kid.
Katrina: 而是说对猫不好
Katrina: It's bad for the cat.
Katrina: 狗都嫌的年纪猫
Katrina: Even a dog wouldn't like it.
Katrina: 狗都嫌的年纪
Katrina: 猫有条猫吵死了你晓得吧
Katrina: Cats can be noisy, you know that?
Katrina: 那小孩子真拿母哈追大炮
Katrina: Kids would just chase them around.
Katrina: 养一个小孩和猫
Katrina: Raising a kid and a cat...
Katrina: 其实受伤的是那只猫哈哈
Katrina: ...the cat is the one who suffers. Haha.
Katrina: 哎呀呀呀呀呀
Katrina: Oh my gosh.
Katrina: 挂了拜拜
Katrina: Hung up, bye.
Katrina: 我收拾房间了
Katrina: I'm cleaning the room now.
Katrina: 拜拜
Katrina: Bye.
Katrina: 充了半个小时还是只有17
Katrina: Been charging for half an hour, still only 17%.
Jake:啥时候买没关系
Jake: Doesn't matter when you buy it.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Lucia: 这个是谁的呀
Lucia: Whose is this?
Katrina: 这个要拿下去吗
Katrina: Should I take this down?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina: 这个要拿下去吗
Katrina: Should I take this down?
Tasha: 嗯好像是的拿来
Tasha: Yeah, I think so, bring it.
Tasha: 拿下去洗就行了
Tasha: Just take it down and wash it.
Tasha: 还有什么要
Tasha: Anything else?
Tasha: 嗯这个能给带下去吗
Tasha: Can you take this down too?
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Sure.
Jake:刮着什么了呀
Jake: What did it scratch?
Jake:刮到啥了呀
Jake:刮刮刮乐刮啊
Jake: Scratch-off lottery, scratch it!
Shure: 啊
Shure: Huh?
Shure: 没买到
Shure: Didn't get it.
Jake:没买到
Jake: Didn't get it.
Jake:哈哈哈没买到是什么东西
Jake: Haha, what do you mean by didn't get it?
Shure: 所以就买了个瓜回来
Shure: So I just bought a melon.
Jake:为什么不开了
Jake: Why didn't you open it?
Jake:倒闭了不是被人没
Jake: Did it close down or what?
Shure: 没没去那家
Shure: No, I didn't go to that one.
Shure: 有一家更近的
Shure: There was one closer.
Shure: 然后我就去那家发现不卖刮刮乐
Shure: So I went there and found out they don't sell scratch-offs.
Shure: 他只卖那种传统的那种
Shure: They only sell the traditional kind.
Jake:那上楼镇一镇
Jake: Then let's go upstairs and calm down.
Shure: 有瓜吃大家
Shure: Everyone, we have melon to eat.
Jake:大伙吃瓜
Jake: Everyone, let's eat melon.
Katrina: i'm not good
Katrina: I'm not good.
Shure: 你不good吗
Shure: You're not good?
Katrina: 我想吐
Katrina: I feel like throwing up.
Katrina: 真可是昨天真的就止一点点
Katrina: But really, just a little bit yesterday.
Katrina: 这凳子是放哪的
Katrina: Where should this chair go?
Jake:刮刮乐没买到
Jake: Didn't get the scratch-offs.
Jake:买了个瓜这
Jake: Got a melon instead.
Jake:强一些应该
Jake: Should be stronger.
Shure: 呀不是雨轩嗯帮忙把那个拿出来
Shure: Hey, isn't it Yuxuan, um, help me take that out.
Katrina: 好啦这个是不是要搬下去了
Katrina: Okay, should we move this down?
Jake:好嘞三九几个呀
Jake: Alright, how many do we have?
Jake:上面应该5个吗 12345
Jake: Should there be 5 on top? 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
Shure: 把我那音箱什么的收一下
Shure: Pack up my speakers and stuff.
Jake:弄下去两个
Jake: Take two down.
Jake:这小马就放上面吧弄下去
Jake: Put this pony on top, then take it down.
Shure: 小马
Shure: Pony?
Shure:  这是Eagle horse
Shure: This is Eagle horse.
Shure: 你要叫他的名字
Shure: You should call it by its name.
Jake:哎一个house
Jake: Oh, a house.
Shure: 月亮和六便士
Shure: "Moon and Sixpence."
Shure: 这不谢斌竹买的吗
Shure: Didn't Xie Binzhui buy this?
Katrina: 我也好困
Katrina: I'm so sleepy too.
Katrina: 睡好但是我起来以后不太舒服
Katrina: I slept well, but I didn't feel good after waking up.
Katrina: 不知道为啥
Katrina: Don't know why.
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure: 都是正常的酒后反应
Shure: It's a normal reaction after drinking.
Katrina: 呃呃
Katrina: Ugh.
Katrina: 吐了
Katrina: I threw up.
Katrina: 吐不出来
Katrina: Can't throw up anymore.
其他人：我找到了
Others: I found it.
Shure: 找到什么了
Shure: Found what?
其他人：找到那个视频了
Others: Found that video.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 收拾一下
Shure: Clean up a bit.
Jake:要搬下去两个
Jake: Need to move two down.
Shure: 这次建模和上次建模有区别吗
Shure: Is there any difference between this modeling and the last one?
Jake:那你觉得有什么区
Jake: What do you think is different?
Jake:你你房间确实没什么区别
Jake: Your room doesn't seem different.
Jake:你房间可以不扫
Jake: You don't need to clean your room.
Tasha: 别
Tasha: No.
Jake:哈哈哈什么
Jake: Haha, what?
Jake:你刚刚说啥
Jake: What did you just say?
Lucia: 我说这个就是如果影响
Lucia: I said, if it bothers you...
Lucia: 你可以放回我房间里
Lucia: You can put it back in my room.
Jake:不影响不影响
Jake: It doesn't bother me.
Lucia: 因为我是在收拾
Lucia: Because I was cleaning up.
Lucia: 所以先把它拿出来了
Lucia: So I took it out first.
Jake:不影响不影响
Jake: It doesn't bother me.
Jake:就是除了你的房间和厕所
Jake: Except for your room and the bathroom...
Jake:别的都有巨大的变化
Jake: Everything else has changed a lot.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahaha
Lucia: 这个并列关系
Lucia: This is a parallel relationship.
Jake:不是事实是这么回事
Jake: No, actually, it's like this.
Lucia: 你是懂修辞的
Lucia: You do understand rhetoric.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha